hahahaha you thought I was done with
this game
think again mother [ __ ] I'm back you
thought I was actually angry from a
video game what do you think I'm some
child do I look like a child to you easy
anyone who hasn't been this game
it's a goddamn dare I say it casual look
at this jump look at this jump oh my god
oh-oh-oh
I'm enjoying myself having a good time
with laughter and friends and making
happy times happy memories wait why am I
going this way Aaron I'm not even
supposed to go this way oh my god
whatever oh wow look at that look at
that everybody look at that turns out
I'm the best player alive how about that
Oh No
okay we're good this bit is so [ __ ]
stupid
seriously this bit is dumb it doesn't
even make any sense
oh good look at that good good good good
come on
[Music]
suck a dick
suck the dick suck the dick circuit sir
ah ah you're so annoying
stop stop stop go up there this bit just
sucks it [ __ ] sucks
thank you my guy you Stratton everybody
and you strike it's like you do one
thing
Congrats now you have to do 500 other
things what are you I think I know what
to do no no that's not where you were
supposed to do oh good yeah oh good oh
good you're here now oh good that's good
that's [ __ ] great
okay we're back everybody how about that
that isn't that great for everybody
oh wow oh
oh no no no we're fine
god damn that's a lot easier oh my god
that was close
No Oh Oh baby steps baby steps we're
taking baby steps everybody there's
nothing wrong with baby steps it's nice
and safe
everyone loves baby steps we all have to
do baby steps oh look oh look we're back
here mr. orange pleased to make your
acquaintance
[ __ ] off Oh God what did I just do
bye-bye
[Music]
okay alright come on come on easy
what did I Oh what all the way all of
the way to the very beginning huh can
this tree suck a dick like what is
happening whatever you know whatever
whatever whatever okay whatever whatever
do I look like I care I don't [ __ ]
care listen I just fell away from the
top of the map to the bottom don't play
this music okay
play some Lincoln part or Evanescence I
need some real emotion oh look at that
you think I care this game is easy I
jumped off on purpose I wanted the
challenge do you think I [ __ ] care do
you think Oh God Oh God not it no stop
falling down you [ __ ]
oh look we're back here by the [ __ ]
lights like this bit isn't annoying at
all [ __ ] have to squeeze a dick to
get through
look I'm breaking the goddamn hammer can
you [ __ ] [ __ ] off the reason I click
500 times is because I changed the DPI
on the [ __ ] Mouse because I get stuck
in these [ __ ] places so I have to it
says more about your [ __ ] game than
me alright it doesn't [ __ ] suck a
dick man I hate this vid it's so
annoying it's just annoying it's just
pure luck if you get through I can't
turn my mouse that fast there we go
there we go finally Jesus Christ okay oh
look we're back here everybody oh isn't
that just great my favourite bit of the
game I'm coming back I'm coming back I'm
coming back maybe I'm coming up I want
the world to know I'm coming back oh
look at that look who's back everybody
it's me booty pie you thought I would
give up didn't ya never give up whenever
I climb
I'm followed by a dog called ego
Friedrich Nietzsche excuse me I thought
I muted you voiceover volume zero
I don't need your knee chase beauts
there we go oh look who's back baby I'm
back and I'm back for blood no no no oh
Jesus Christ
what's wrong with you if your dick
didn't get so [ __ ] hard this wouldn't
be so hard oh my god oh I did it
okay that works too I guess what the
[ __ ] did I do
I'm coming I'm back baby you thought I
was gonna quit good job he thought I was
gonna quit dead jack wedding is for
losers
do I look like a look hey relax relax
look who's back baby oh look who's back
mr. orange look who is back baby easy
that was so easy my god
I'm gonna climb this mountain thank you
very much
all right we cool now don't push me down
like you did last time please okay okay
okay I'm just trying to get the damn
right angle I don't know how the heck I
went down last time like that that's so
easy here's when the hard bit comes
easy
Hey No
hold hold on hold on everyone okay okay
okay it's a cat's okay it's okay
everybody it's okay okay sigh ah ah fine
[Music]
easy
no no [ __ ] honestly I'm fine
I'm doing great I'm doing great Oh
oh that's great no no no no no that's
just what I wanted oh no no keep folding
keep falling stop oh now I gotta do the
lights again I hate the [ __ ] lights
okay it's not [ __ ] funny at this
point